we're going to turn now to our series
changing the game which highlights
extraordinary women and for Black
History Month we're going to highlight
black women making a difference in their
fields now and for future Generations
this morning we are introducing you to
Angel Gregorio she is the founder of the
spice Suite it's a specialty shop in
Washington DC that sells unique spice
Blends and condiments since launching in
2015 the spice Suite has also hosted
thousands of pop-up shops from more than
450 black owned businesses Angel
Gregorio here with us this morning
welcome you have the best line about
your business that I've ever seen you
said it is the spice shop and dream
incubator yes explain that so of course
we're a Spice Shop Right everyone knows
that we have spices Honeys olives all
the sexy things for food but what I
think folks come to us for and they stay
a while is because we allow other black
businesses space to expand businesses so
we call ourselves a dream incubator
because some come with just a dream and
that dream grows after popping up at our
store Well you certainly have the dream
this was not what you were working in
all the time you were an assistant
principal yes when this dream of yours
started so how did you end up in this
business yeah I literally say I'm living
a dream I didn't even know I had right
I hear it's the most serendipitous thing
ever I was walking down the street I saw
a felican I called the landlord wanting
to know what the rent would be and I
thought it was like an apartment like if
I ask you the rent you tell me right but
he had some legitimate questions like
what do you want to do with the space
and I was like oh I don't know I have no
idea and he's like well we need to know
before I tell you the rent and I was
like sir I'm going to open a Spice Shop
can you just tell me the price
and I it's stuck and three and a half
weeks later I opened a spice shop I left
my job two months after that and that
was almost eight years ago why a spice
shop I don't know I don't know what made
me I didn't grow up going to spice shops
when I opened there were other spice
shops in DC that I'd never been into we
are now the only Spice Shop left in DC
Egypt sorry Angel I know we're here to
talk about spices but your style has got
me like speechless here thank you you
say food is fashion how so because I
feel like we should mix and match and
take risks in our kitchens and our
closets like don't think so hard about
what you're wearing or how you're
flavoring food folks come into the spice
suite and because they're overwhelmed
because there's so many spices the first
question is almost always what should I
put on my chicken and I'm like girl I
don't even know you I don't know what
you want your chicken to taste like like
and it's like walking into a department
store saying what should I wear today
right like they don't know you they
don't know what you feel most
comfortable with like I don't know the
rules I didn't go to culinary school so
I'm not here to tell you what you should
flavor your food with I'm just here to
provide you with a bunch of options yeah
yeah just try it you've been to 36
countries trying different spices and
you make your own Unique Blends yeah
what do you look for so as really go
spices their fellow Spice Girls all over
the world and so I really just go
wanting to know what they cook with in
Africa or in Asia and India wherever I
am and I come back inspired to create a
similar flavor profile or maybe inspired
by the colors that I see that might
inspire me okay so go back to that
assistant principle for a minute yeah
teacher right so people watching they'll
be like oh that's nice but now help
Inspire folks watching who want to do
something as original as you did yes so
I think my advice to folks is always
start now perfect later right and I say
that because sometimes I think that we
get in our own heads and we think that
we can't start the thing until it's
perfect in our heads and then we can
make it perfect in real life but the
reality is it might not ever be right
like there were several iterations of
the spice Suite in terms of our bottles
our branding where we are now is not
where we'll be in five years I don't
know where we'll be but I'm sure it
won't look like it does now so sometimes
we just have to get started you provide
that opportunity too for a lot of people
as well black and fourth yeah the first
black owned strip mall yes again I sort
of go to where did the idea come from
but why so important also to provide
this opportunity for people yeah I think
that so the idea for the strip mall was
also random I did not plan to do that I
was just looking for a commercial space
to purchase because I was outgrowing my
small space that I was renting and when
I saw this former like tow truck company
that was this huge building with garage
doors and set on a huge parking lot I
immediately knew I could not occupy all
this space by myself I knew I wanted to
bring some black people along with me on
this journey and I wanted to start a
bigger conversation about affordable
commercial space we talked nationally
about affordable housing but if small
business is the backbone of the country
then folks need more than an online shop
right like you need a brick and mortar
space and so if I have space then I can
share it with you what if you learned
about yourself in this process I mean
you've got you don't know where you're
going to be in five years yeah it sounds
like you didn't know where you were
going to be 10 years ago right now what
have you discovered I've discovered that
I am much more risky than I thought like
I I knew that I took risks in fashion
right like I've been that way since
childhood I've always won crazy things
but I did not realize that I could take
this much risk in real life that I could
go and be so bold and so audacious in
the way that I've been and so it shocks
me sometimes that this is my life one
more thing before we go are you doing
what sets your soul on fire absolutely I
feel free I feel so free feel like I'm
I don't feel like I work that's a
blessing it's a beautiful thing and to
your point people should feel free when
they're making dinner as well you don't
have to follow the recipe just try the
different spices Just Go With It worst
case scenario she's not a good Fork full
yeah make it again yeah make it again
angel I got to tell people you said this
also when we started my only goal was to
never have to go to my bank account and
pay the rent that was year one year
three I was like if I could pay myself a
salary I'd be happy you're five
everything changed good for you thank
you so much thank you so much Angel
Gregorio thank you continued success in
helping others as well